ah scoop that uh just kidding okay
welcome back everybody to just cause for
why did I say welcome back so one of the
things they've added to just cost for a
I absolutely loved it's the retract away
what is it
if the booster that's right he's fine
have a great day sir what are you
looking at bye-bye you can do some weird
stuff in this hey I like your haircut
you grab that and your grab that oh it's
not a retracting oh it is white and go
ah damn it and go bye-bye they also
added one of my favorite things which is
the balloons excuse me bye-bye we go
together we ride hard we die hard this
video please guys do not send this video
to box whatever you do we're going on an
adventure
Pearson ciao everybody get out Jesus
don't worry mr. cow just let's hope we
don't run into any bridges oh my god
what is happening what just happened
get out of my car dude
Jesus Christ what's happened I didn't
even do anything
don't run away so can I ride the car
there you go Wow it's the car with
people the human car Oh No Oh No hey
she's coming back we have a bunch of
people right god damn it
okay let's let's just keep it let's just
keep adding people you want to join my
party come on join just walking down the
streets and you're dead and you're part
of the party
now wait what is it touch oh god damn it
[Music]
are they dead I like I can't tell now
we're a what goddamn it goddamn it
this always happens yes yes hey aah
stay up and now we're at oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah I got it who had fun today I had
fun today
wait wait wait wait sorry I just got an
idea what if I put this on the motorbike
no wait that's wrong okay god dammit
this is not what I wanted
while this car is not nearly fast enough
if there was it was only away I can make
it faster get it get it that's it that's
it now we're at Hey Oh on the check get
it get it damn it
see this is how the game was meant to be
played everyone knows things here we go
this world hey guys please be careful
there's a grate right there Oh awesome a
helicopter yay let's go boys
wow what a right why is the most fun in
this game just to terrorize people and
dude is that a freaking boat oh hell
yeah can I Drive it oh my god alright
then alright then but what if the boat
could fly as well there she goes there
nay yes
she's flying I think I'm stuck inside
the boat I think a glitch myself God
ever hey how could I break the game
that's ridiculous
see you later boat you've done well now
can I ride a pig
nope that just kicks him sorry oh wait
that's why sorry sigh sigh sigh sigh
sigh sorry sorry I did it wrong I did it
wrong I did it wrong god damn it oh yeah
that's what I'm freakin talking about
guys please I'm just it's a video game
alright I'm sorry wait they have fighter
jets I need that I need it
Oh
oh my god what's up man
that's right now bang let's freakin do
these
oh my god this is where the fun begins
hey hey oh ho oh ho oh god the
helicopter is spinning oh Jesus
vampire why would you need a helicopter
when you can make your own god damn it
Oh oh my god
Hey look it's - on everybody here
remember that one get in get in that's
it
spin spin like you've never there it is
this is the on modded version of the
game by the way
oh my god we're gonna create a ball what
am I even doing I'm not even playing the
king shut up this is how I play games
god damn it oh my god what is wrong with
this guy maybe not oh my god well I
can't oh there it is there it is okay
perfect okay
alright so now just reverse
this room let's reverse now let's just
reverse all right we're doing a shortcut
we're doing this short head we're doing
a live I'm doing a live everybody I'm
doing a life okay we're poor halfway
and I'm alive what the hell is happening
there
what is that what can I do that but Bush
you miss the truck I'm not aiming for
the truck just kidding it was a joke
sorry I'm kidding I'm joking let's just
light and now a perfect landing
executed by the perfect pilot all right
I need to slow down
we need to speed
[Music]
are they haven't they have a
of control speed
[Music]
let's line this baby flawless
part of life
[Music]
[Applause]
this is ridiculous
okay well that was just cause for hope
you guys had fun watching smash like for
more epic gameplay don't tell media
production sponsored by thank you and
Merry Christmas
[Music]
you want pyramids we got oh oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy we got it all
this game is still relevant goddammit